au feu de bois rate moi je sais pas si
tu fais une faveur connaît ce qui est
sûr c'est que l on connaît plus sur les
bouquins vous connaissiez vous le crêpe
au football non mais je pense que ça
doit être très bon là ça va pas être mal
du tout bon quand on est petit et qu'on
s'intéresse à la lecture on fait
confiance à ses parents c'est à dire
nous oui ou même aux grands parents
parfois mais on sait pas toujours qu
acheter surtout quand on a envie que nos
enfants partent un petit peu la tête
dans les étoiles et là typhaine arrive
avec le conseil à glisser sous le sapin
de quoi vous voulez nous parler et bien
les cerfs-volants cerf-volant photo mais
alors comment faire pour parler des
cerfs-volants dans un livre à votre avis
j'en appelle nasser qui est champion du
monde de cerfs-volants et qui vit en
bourgogne et bien sûr plaire il va
beaucoup lui plaire salubre et vous en
livre de mathilde beaumont et regarder
quand on vous et bien les cerfs-volants
jaillissent du papier ce jeudi c'est un
livre pop up et mathilde moreau et bien
c'est une spécialiste des pop up et elle
a décidé de faire revivre donc la
tradition un asiatique des cerfs-volants
et donc on voit est bien le grand
phoenix faig jaillir du papier et au fur
et à mesure donc des pages on voit de
plus en plus de cerfs-volants alors ils
sont cédés cerfs-volants de la tradition
asiatique et donc comme ça les enfants
et bien passer un petit moment la tête
dans les nuages
à découvrir tous ces cerfs-volants
sochaux là c'est bon ça me blesse
j'étais ceux qui savent aussi la bo
derek se balancer à celle gautier
languereau et puis ajoute le conseil
c'est vraiment un joli moment poétique
d'un super on va s'intéresser tient
toujours au gros ciel peut-être même à
l'espace parce que c'est vrai que les
enfants s'intéresse très tôt à à
l'espace comme le héros de votre livre
je crois voilà c'est un livre qui
s'appelle à travers deux tomes en maths
c'est publié chez aux éditions thierry
magnier et alors là on suit en fait
toute la vie d'un jeune garçon de 1956 à
son décès en fait et vous voyez ce qui
est très intéressante sur la longueur
des tarawih ces cas ça se passe en fait
sur deux pages
alors d'abord il ya le héros et puis le
jeune lecteur est bien voir ce que le
héros voit c'est pour ça que ça
s'appelle à travers figurez-vous un cas
on voit
eh bien à travers les feuilles à travers
le télé cela je me comprends voilà à
travers à bien la fenêtre est comme ça
me suis à toute sa vie et comme c'est un
passionné des étoiles figurez vous qu'il
va finir par réaliser son rêve
travailler à la nasa et grâce à ses
livres ensuite et bien la vie de ce
garçon mais on suit aussi tout à la
conquête spatiale américaine
alors c'est un livre que j'ai adoré vous
voyez il est à peu près en quadrichromie
c'est de très belle facture et je le
conseille à partir de 6 ans mais ça
plaira aussi aux adultes c'est très
émouvant
vraiment voilà je conseille à tout le
monde et c'était sélectionné à pour les
pépites du salon du livre de montreuil
la la semaine dernière malheureusement
ça n'a pas gagné c'est mon coup de coeur
non mais là bas j'aime bien j'aime bien
ternes et puis je vais le faire passer
aussi à mes camarades de jeu du téléthon
ça va me permettre de poser une petite
question rapide s'il vous plaît cécile
rouillon
est-ce que vous donner un petit document
aussi à celles et ceux qui
malheureusement souffre de maladies ont
parlé tout à l'heure de l'aide aux
familles que vous faites en bourgogne
franche comté au travers de votre
service vous avez un petit guide un
petit dépliant que vous leur donnez oui
alors on a notre plaquette de
présentation du service la plaquette de
la présentation aussi des différents
réseaux et des réseaux bénévoles aussi
de l'association et au delà de ça nous
avons un service documentaire qui nous
produit des documents thématiques sur la
prévention qui est vraiment un domaine
très important
la prise des prises en charge
cardio-respiratoire et c'est parfait
merci ccct rapide c'était précis c'était
concis comme avec vous d'ailleurs tiffen
on va partir vers vers l'espace vous
saviez qu'il y avait des facteurs dans
l'espace wasquehal 9e pole je suis sûr
que notre espace est un facteur un peu
particulier alors c'est publié aux
éditions la pastèque et figurez vous que
ce facteur est complètement déboussolée
parce qu'on lui change sa tournée lui il
a l'habitude de faire toujours la même
tournée de rencontres et toujours les
mêmes gens à bord de son vaisseau et ce
jour là son chef lui dis bah voilà c'est
fini
aujourd'hui tu va livrer d'autres
personnes et alors lui les complètement
perdu et se retrouve sur des planètes
inconnues avec des colis aux formes
complètement extravagantes et voilà
alors c'est un il y aura très drôle qui
demande dessinée
vous voyez et c'est ça plaira beaucoup
aux enfants parce que finalement le
message c'est prenez des risques
n'hésitez pas à rencontrer des
personnages loufoques et on se demande
parfois si on va pas rencontrer le petit
prince dans cette voie là parce que tous
les personnages sont plus drôles les uns
que les autres
il ya des tomates gigantesque qui pousse
sur ces planètes
il ya des chiens qui vivent en autonomie
vraiment c'est un vrai coup de coeur
c'est très sympa c'est pour le jeune
lecteur à partir de 8 ans on va dire ça
se lit très bien je vous le conseille
et bien sûr un petit dernier conseil
pour la route à glisser sous le sapin
pour autrui alors ça c'est pour les plus
grands c'est à partir de 13 ans ça
s'appelle le peuple de la brume c'est
publia la joie de lire alors c'est écrit
par un brésilien josé eduardo agualusa
est en fait vous savez qu'on nous
annonce le déluge la montée des eaux
malheureusement alors imaginer que le
peuple en fait les êtres humains se
réfugient dans les airs sur des
dirigeables et les villages et bien dans
ce livre sont des dirigeables aggloméré
en fait et on découvre comment vivent en
fait les êtres humains à ce moment là
parce que figurez vous que vous et moi
eh bien on regrette la terre on les
animaux courir sentir l'odeur de la
terre humide et voilà c'est l'histoire
de ce livre c'est poétique philosophique
et je le conseille aux enfants à partir
de 13 ans allez le peuple de la brume
merci typhaine pour cette sélection
livre glisser sous le sapin rêver ben
oui il faut bien rêver c'est important
vous avez